pure eggs on a plastic sheet spread over
a damp floor and the clothes on their
backs are all yellow play gotcha and his
family have left a legacy of Central
African Republic 6-year conflict he says
this holding facility in the capital
bengi is his fourth home
so the civil war began in 2013 and now
his children have been diagnosed with
malnutrition some with severe cases
sometimes you get a little food we get
only a cup of rice not enough to feed a
family like mine my children are
malnourished
I'm just waiting and hoping that one day
thing will get better the ana paula is
one of 2,700,000 people displaced by the
crisis which is 52 percent of the
population the United Nations says it is
still struggling to reach tens of
thousands of people affected in the
nation where two-thirds live on less
than $8 a month people who have not
received assistance over three four five
years and those who have been seeing for
the last 12 months we've been reaching
these people for the first time and
groups are preventing humanitarian
workers reaching areas in need of
assistance they also not allowing
civilians to go seek for help the food
shortages are made worse by natural
disasters including climate change the
price of cassava flour the staple food
for many people here has risen sharply
over the past few months after flooding
has destroyed many farm lands as a
result the number of people requiring
food aid including farmers who are one
serve reliant is rising steadily
humanitarian workers say food shortages
and inflation will get worse as the lean
months draw closer putting more people
at risk for Ana Paula Gocha and his
family it could be devastating they say
that after six years on the move they
have nowhere else to go how many trees
al-jazeera
monkey